okay wie erkläre ich das jetzt am besten
und ich war neugierig leute was geht ab
ich hoffe euch geht's gut ich habe
letztens was verrücktes bestellt glaube
ich also ich war wirklich neugierig weil
ich bin mir nicht sicher was das ist ist
es einfach nur eine ganz normale coca
cola flasche aus spanien oder ist es
doch irgendwas anderes ich dachte mir
ich bestellt einfach mal wir müssen uns
das auch erstmal auf jeden fall genauer
anschauen das machen wir jetzt aber es
geht um eine coca cola flasche 125
litern 35 euro also ich hab wirklich 35
euro dafür bezahlt vielleicht ist da ja
auch irgendwas anderes drin oder so aber
takt jetzt erstmal ab was ich da
bestellt und damit etwas geht ab und
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute ich hoffe natürlich euch jedes gut
mich hat ein zuschauer darauf aufmerksam
dass ist bayerisch anscheinend ein drink
coca cola höher 24 euro plus 11 euro
versand hab mir das angeguckt und ich
habe das halt wie gesagt einiger zeit
einfach mal bestellt weil ich irgendwie
das nicht glauben konnte oder hier so
sieht das auf jeden fall aus ich weiß
nicht wahrscheinlich dürfen die nicht
die originalen flaschen verwenden oder
vielleicht ist es auch gar keine echte
cola kein plan auf jeden fall gebt euch
das hier einfach 24 euro plus 11 euro
versand das heißt ich habe hier cola
bestellt für 35 euro in fue looking for
new market training items wie präsident
wäre fracturing coca cola also
anscheinend wirklich coca cola warum ist
das so teuer ich bin wirklich mal
gespannt was da ankommt also irgendwie
ist das alles ein bisschen merkwürdig
muss das jetzt eben noch bei der post
abholen da liegt hat nämlich und dann
packen wir es mal aus mal gucken was
dann drin ist ich wollte mir jetzt
wenigstens einmal hier den shop
anschauen von denen weil das ist ja
alles ein bisschen dubios hat haben die
dann noch so ein angebot ein fahrrad für
1000 euro
red bull für 15 euro he leger warum ist
das alles so teuer bei euch 250
milliliter red bull für 15 euro verkauft
das außer mir die haben wirklich sehr
sehr viele auch teure sachen wie neu
wusste gar nicht dass es auch ruhig so
viele teure sachen dann doch gibt ihr
könnt ja so kann jetzt schon mal
kommentieren warum denkt ist das so
teuer vielleicht ist da ja irgendwie
koks drin oder so packe ich jetzt aus
also warte mal kurz es ist nicht
schwerer als 125 kilo würde ich mal
sagen deswegen
ist jetzt hier anscheinend wirklich
einfach also ich komme ja auch gar nicht
klar wieso kann man bayerisch eine
colaflasche bestellen für 35 euro
verkaufen das also das wird doch niemand
kaufen außer ich jetzt für ein
youtube-video wie kommt man überhaupt
darauf so was dort anzubieten wir machen
das jetzt einmal auf 1 2
weil okay jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
falls das heute ein sehr kurzes video
werde entschuldige ich mich schon mal
dafür aber was soll ich machen kann ist
auch eine rechnung weil
ja denn ich viel dreck auch noch gemacht
wie fresh inc coca-cola
1,25 liter also ich würde euch die
flasche firma ab das sieht ein bisschen
ich weiß auch nicht da ist so klebeband
darüber warum das so ist gute frage man
muss aber sagen auf der rechnung steht
nicht der preis wahrscheinlich schäden
die sich dafür nice links ach so das ist
der name vom shop da gucke ich mal kurz
rein was ich noch so verkaufen
wahrscheinlich fand dafür 41 euro ich
würde mal sagen ich habe mir eben ein
glas und probieren wir mal aber eine
sache die mir auffällt guck mal eine
richtige coca cola flasche geht doch
bisher oder ist doch bis hierhin voll
doch nicht nur bis hierhin das sieht ja
so aus als hätte da schon jemand raus
getrunken oder bin ich doof und auch
dieses klebeband herum also was ist ganz
ganz komisch warum macht man das so als
wäre ich schon mal auf gewesen war da
ist doch irgendwas schon raus getrunken
beschreibt darin die kommentare bin ich
doof oder normalerweise sind jedoch viel
voller bis hierhin so
[Musik]
das liegt eventuell auch am transporter
weiß es nicht irgendwie ein bisschen
eklig deswegen hole ich mir jetzt mal
eben glass naja blog das hier ist
übrigens sein büro für die diesmal
interessiert also hier ist eine küche
saß
und hier kommen wir wieder zu mir
herzlich willkommen leute das müsst ihr
euch jetzt mal geben ich schütte hier
jetzt was ein und man kann ja quasi
sagen pro schlug den ich jetzt gleich
hier trinken werde könnte ich quasi in
den supermarkt gehen und mir eine
colaflasche kaufen die genauso groß ist
ein schluck 1 euro wer hat noch nicht
wer will noch das ist nicht das teuerste
getränk was sich hier getrunken habe das
war in las vegas und wasser ich kam aus
dem klub wieder hat mir so ein fiddy
wasser genommen aus der minibar das
getrunken am nächsten morgen gesehen
okay das kostet 15 euro plus 50 euro
wenn jemand kommt und ein neues wasser
bringt also 65 euro eigentlich und die
koki die ich jetzt trinke kostet halt
nur 35 euro im schnäppchen ok
[Musik]
morgen youtuber an falscher cola
gestorben deliziosa ihre frisch ganze
sabor original ich glaube die kommt aus
spanien baby da rief er ist ja was soll
ich dazu noch sagen also ist alles ein
bisschen komisch man muss sagen es
schmeckt wie ganz normale cola auch die
kohlensäure super enthalten einplanen
warum also 50 milliliter gefehlt haben
vielleicht ist das ja auch in spanien so
dass die nicht sofort sondern in
deutschland aber 35 euro kosten die
sicherlich in spanien audio 24 euro plus
11 euro versand
welcher informatives video leute ich
muss jetzt leider schon sagen ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen dieses video
immerhin die person die mir geschrieben
hat weiß jetzt dass sie diese cola
besser nicht bestellen sollte oder weiß
oder ihr alle bis jetzt dass da einfach
nur ganz normale co dahinter steckt halt
35 euro kostet das ist finde ich
geisteskrank ich habe jetzt hier gerade
noch eine refreshing coca cola gefunden
allerdings nur 500 milliliter für 23
euro das ist ja noch frecher plus 11
euro versand also ich hoffe dass sie
dadurch gefallen ich habe auch noch mehr
würde sachen bestellt da gibt es jetzt
in zukunft wieder öfter mal war es das
super gerne daumen nach oben da bestellt
diese coca cola nicht geht einfach ihren
laden dann spart ihr 34 euro pro drei
leute